what's happened to the hundreds of
billions of U.S dollars we've sent to
Ukraine no clue who organized those BLM
riots three years ago no one's gotten to
the bottom of that what exactly happened
on 9 11 well it's still classified how
did Jeffrey Epstein make all that money
how did he die how about JFK and so
endlessly on not only are the media not
interested in any of this they are
actively hostile to anybody who is in
journalism curiosity is the gravest
crime secrecy is a powerful tool of
control stop asking how we got so rich
here's another story about racism go eat
each other it is very clear that the
guy's voice should be heard he should
have the ability to cover the issues
that he wants to cover to talk about the
things that he thinks are important the
point is the guy is back